WE HAVE THAT AND COACH MORE IN
THE BREAKING NEWS OPENING NIGHT
MONOLOGUE.
ALL RIGHT, LET’S START WITH WHAT
THE MEDIA WILL NOT TELL YOU
TONIGHT.
SOME OF THE BIGGEST NEWS IN
NOT INCLUDED.
IT DOES NOT SAY THAT DONALD
TRUMP COLLUDED WITH THE
RUSSIANS.
IT DOES NOT SAY THAT ANYBODY ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN COLLUDED WITH
THE RUSSIANS.
IT DOES NOT SAY THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP OBSTRUCTLED JUSTICE.
IT DOES NOT SAY THAT DONALD
TRUMP JR. ATTEMPTED TO COLLUDE
WITH THE RUSSIANS.
THE SAME GOES FOR LT. GENERAL
MICHAEL FLYNN AND ATTORNEY
GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS.
THE BIGGEST EXAMPLES OF RUSSIAN
COLLUSION FOR 2016 THAT WE KNOW
ABOUT, THAT WE HAVE REAL
CONCRETE EVIDENCE OF, IS, ONE,
HILLARY CLINTON, BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR DOSSIER.
THE ONE THAT USED RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT SOURCES TO PEDDLE
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA, LIES, TO
INFLUENCE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN
THE PAST ELECTION IN 2016.
AND THE OTHER EXAMPLE IS THAT WE
KNOW TO BE TRUE, DEALS WITH
URANIUM ONE AND VLADIMIR PUTIN
AND PEOPLE HE HAD ON THE GROUND
IN AMERICA INVOLVED IN BRIBERY
AND MONEY LAUNDERING AND
KICKBACK AND RACKETEERING
SCHEMES TOOK PLACE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WE WILL HAVE MORE ON THIS LATER
TONIGHT.
BUT FIRST THE KEY POINTS FROM
THIS INDICTMENT.
13 RUSSIAN NATIONALS, THREE
RUSSIAN COMPANIES, LAUNCHED THE
CAMPAIGN OF INFORMATION WARFARE.
IT STARTED BACK IN 2014.
AND EVENTUALLY CULL MY NALTED IN
INTERFERING WITH THE 2016
ELECTION.
THE GOAL WAS SIMPLE, SEW
POLITICAL DISCORD IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
YEAH, NO KIDDING.
WE HAVE BEEN TELLING YOU ALL
ABOUT URANIUM ONE, ALL ABOUT THE
DOSSIER, FILLED WITH RUSSIAN
LIES.
NOW THIS IS CRITICAL.
AFTER THE ELECTION THE SAME
RUSSIAN TROLLS THAT ATTEMPTED TO
UNDERMINE THEN PRESIDENT-ELECT
DONALD TRUMP, WELL THEY WENT OUT
THERE, PRESIDENT TRUMP FINALLY
IS REACTING TO THIS TODAY, THEY
WERE UNDERMINING THE PRESIDENT
AFTER THE ELECTION.
RUSSIA STARTED THEIR ANTI-U.S.
CAMPAIGN IN 2014, LONG BEFORE HE
ANNOUNCED THAT HE WOULD RUN FOR
PRESIDENT.
HE SAID I.
AND THEN THE RESULTS OF THE
ELECTION WERE NOT IMPACTED.
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN DID NOTHING
WRONG, NO COLLUSION.
THE WHOUT WHITE HOUSE PUT OUT A
STATEMENT, IT IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER BEFORE TO COME
TOGETHER AS AMERICANS.
WE CANNOT ALLOW THOSE SEEKING TO
SEW CONFUSION, DISCORD, RANCOR
TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
IT’S TIME WE STOP THE OUTLANDISH
PARTISAN ATTACKS, THE WILD FALSE
OCEANS, FAR FETCHED THEY ARIES
THAT SERVE TO FURTHER THE
AGENDAS OF BAD ACTORS LIKE
RUSSIA AND DO NOTHING TO PROTECT
THE PRINCIPLES OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS.
WE MUST UNITE AS AMERICANS TO
PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
ELECTIONS.
WHAT THIS SHOWS IS NOTHING SHORT
OF A SOPHISTICATED EFFORT BY THE
RUSSIANS TO GAIN INFLUENCE IN
AMERICA.
NOW, WE HAVE BEEN TELLING YOU
THIS, ABOUT VLADIMIR PUTIN,
ABOUT RUSSIAN OPERATIVES, ABOUT
HOW THEY’VE BEEN INVOLVED IN
SOPHISTICATED SCHEMES.
WE HAVE BEEN GOING BACK TO AS
EARLY AS 2009.
REMEMBER, HE HAD PEOPLE,
OPTATIVES, ON THE GROUND WITH
THE PURPOSE OF BREAKING INTO
AMERICA’S URANIUM MARKET.
WE ALSO TOLD YOU HOW THOSE
RUSSIAN OPERATIVES WERE INVOLVED
AND WE KNEW IT BECAUSE WE HAD AN
INSIDER ON THE GROUND, FBI INFOR
MANLT THAT, THEY WERE INVOLVED
IN BRIBERY, KICKBACKS, MONEY
LAUNDERING, RACK KEERING, ALL IN
A SCHEME TIED ON HILLARY
CLINTON.
NOW THAT’S THE DEAL WITH THE
CLINTON STATE DEPARTMENT AND
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
THEY IGNORED THIS FBI
INVESTIGATION.
WHAT THIS INFORMANT WAS TELLING
THEM WAS GOING ON IN THE INSIDE.
AND INEXPLICABLY THEY APPROVED
IN 2010 GIVING VLADIMIR PUTIN
CONTROL OF OVER 20% OF AMERICA’S
URANIUM MARKET.
WE HAD THE INFORMANT WARNING US
ON THE INSIDE THE ENTIRE TIME.
NOBODY LISTENED.
AND THE CLUELESS MEDIA IGNORED
THIS RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE.
NOW, THIS ONLY MATTERS
APPARENTLY IF THE RUSSIANS ARE
INVOLVED, IF YOU CAN USE IT TO
BLUDGEON PRESIDENT TRUMP
POLITICALLY.
SADLY, PUTIN AND RUSSIA WERE
SUCCESSFUL IN 2010, GOT THE
URANIUM.
EVEN THOUGH WE ALREADY HAVE A
SHORTAGE OF URANIUM IN AMERICA
WE HAVE TO IMPORT URANIUM.
LET’S GET BACK TO THE
INDICTMENT.
IT LAYS OUT ALLEGATIONS THAT
BEGIN IN 2014.
WHERE RUSSIAN NATIONALS, THEY
WERE WORKING TOGETHER, WITH A
TROLL FARM LOCATED IN
ST. PETERSBURG, RUSSIA TRYING TO
INFLUENCE THE ELECTION.
WHY NOT AFTER THEY GOT THE
URANIUM.
THEY POSED AS U.S. PERSONS AND
CREATING FALSE U.S. PERSONAS,
OOMENTED SOCIAL MEDIA PAGES AND
GROUPS TO ATTRACT U.S.
AUDIENCES.
THEY STAGED POLITICAL RALLIES
WHILE PRETENDING TO BE AMERICAN
POLITICAL ACTIVISTS AND PAID
AMERICANS IN THE U.S. TO ATTACK
CERTAIN CANDIDATES.
THIS OPERATION AT A MONTHLY
BUDGE EMENT OF OVER $1 MILLION,
RUSSIANS OPERATING INSIDE THIS
COUNTRY.
JUST LIKE THEY WERE IN 2009.
IN THIS CASE, AGAIN, THE
RUSSIANS GOT CAUGHT RED HANDED.
AS WE HAVE BEEN EXPLAINING,
THERE WERE NO AMERICANS,
INCLUDING ANYBODY FROM THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, THAT WERE INVOLVED AND
THESE EFFORTS DID NOT IMPACT THE
ELECTION RESULTS.
HERE’S WHAT THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL, ROD ROSENSTEIN, SAID
EARLIER TODAY.
>> THERE IS NO ALLEGATION IN
THIS INDICTMENT THAT ANY
AMERICAN WAS A KNOWING
PARTICIPANT IN THIS ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY.
THERE IS NO ALLEGATION IN THE
INDICTMENT THAT THE CHARGE
CONDUCT ALTERED THE OUTCOME OF
THE 2016 ELECTION.
>> Sean: YOU PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA
THAT PAID NO ATTENTION TO PUTIN
AND URANIUM, PAY CLOSE ATTENTION
HERE.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> RUSSIANS ALSO RECRUITED AND
PAID REAL AMERICANS TO ENGAGE IN
POLITICAL ACTIVITIES, PROMOTE
POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS, AND STAGE
POLITICAL RALLIES.
THE DEFENDANTS AND THEIR
CO-CONSPIRATORS PRESENT TENDED
TO BE GRASSROOTS ACTIVE
INTERESTS.
THE AMERICANS DID NOT KNOW THEY
WERE COMMUNICATING WITH RUSSIANS
ACCORDING TO THE INDICTMENT.
AFTER THE ELECTION, THE
DEFENDANTS ALLEGEDLY STAGED
RALLIES TO SUPPORT THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY STAGING RALLIES
TO PRO TERNLT HIS ELECTION.
-- PROTEST.
FOR EXAMPLE THE KEFTS, ONNED ONE
RALLY TO SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT
ELECT AND ANOTHER RALLY TO
IMPOSE -- OPPOSE HIM, BOTH IN
NEW YORK ON THE SAME DAY.
>> Sean: BOTH THE SAME DAY.
THE RUSSIANS WERE ORGANIZING
RALLIES AND ENGAGING IN
POLITICAL ACTIVITIES FOR BOTH
CAMPAIGNS.
AFTER THE ELECTION THEY WERE
SEEKING TO UNDERMINE
THEN-PRESIDENT-ELECT DONALD
TRUMP.
HERE’S HOW IT LAYS OUT N OR
AROUND NOVEMBER OF 2016 THEY
ORGANIZED A RALLY IN NEW YORK
THROUGH ONE ORGANIZATION,
CONTROL GROUPS, DESIGNED TO SHOW
YOUR SUPPORT FOR PRESIDENT-ELECT
DONALD TRUMP HELD ON OR ABOUT
NOVEMBER 12, 2016.
AT THE EXACT SAME TIME, DEFLTS
AND THEIR CO-RESPONSIBLE
SPIRTORS THROUGH ANOTHER
ORGANIZATION GROUP ORGANIZELED A
RALLY ALSO IN NEW YORK CALLED
TRUMP IS 234089 MY PRESIDENT
HELD ON OR ABOUT NOVEMBER 1,
2016.
SIMILARLY, DEFENDANTS AND THEIR
CO-RESPONSIBLE SPIRTORS
ORGANIZED A RALLY CALLED
CHARLOTTE AGAINST TRUMP N
CHARLOTTE, NORTH CAROLINA.
HELD ON OR ABOUT NOVEMBER 19,
2016.
THIS WASN’T AS ONE-SIDED AS THE
MEAD YEAS TRYING TO MAKE IT OUT
TO BE.
IN FACT THIS INDICTMENT
CONTINUES TO PROVE THAT THE
MEDIA HAS BEEN WRONG AND LYING
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, NO
EVIDENCE, FOR OVER A YEAR NOW
PUSHING THEIR BIZARRE CONSPIRACY
THEY ARIES ABOUT TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
THAT IS NONEXISTENT.
YOU MAY REMEMBER THIS.
>> A DIZZYING.
4 HOURS IN THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION NO, LONGER JUST
INCHING TOWARD THE PRESIDENT.
THIS MORNING IT IS MORE LIKE
CAREENING.
>> I THINK THIS IS A POTENTIALLY
MORE DANGEROUS SITUATION THAN
WATERGATE.
WE’RE AT A DANGEROUS MOMENT.
THAT’S BECAUSE WE ARE LOOKING AT
THE POSSIBILITY THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND THOSE AROUND HIM DURING AN
ELECTION CAMPAIGN COLLUDED WITH
A HOSTILE FOREIGN POWER TO
UNDERMINE THE BASIS OF OUR
DEMOCRACY.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS AFRAID, A
POLITICAL HURRICANE IS OUT THERE
AT SEA FOR HIM.
WE’LL CALL IT HURRICANE
VLADAMIR, THE WHOLE RUSSIAN
THING.
>> THIS IS EVIDENCE OF
WILLINGNESS TO COMMIT COLLUSION.
>> THERE’S OUTRIGHT TROE SON,
THERE’S NO -- TREASON, NO
QUESTION WHAT HE’S DOING IS
GIVING AID AND COMFORT TO THE
ENEMY.
>> THEY SAY THE ELECTION HACKING
IS AT THE CALIBER OF A PEARL
HARBOR OR 9/S 1.
DO YOU FREE?
>> I COMPLETELY AGREE.
>> DONALD TRUMP NOW SITS AT THE
THRESHOLD OF IMPEACHMENT.
>> Sean: IT’S BEEN OVER A YEAR
THESE TYPES OF COMMENTS WITHOUT
ANY EVIDENCE, FACTS OBVIOUSLY
DON’T MATTER TO THE FAKE NEWS
MEDIA.
NO EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
THIS INDICTMENT SAYS NO
AMERICAN, NO MEMBER OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN WITTINGLY TRIED TO HELP
THE RUSSIANS.
A LOT OF PEEP PEOPLE ARE SHOCKED
BY THE INDICTMENT, A GASP FROM
THE NEWS MEDIA WHEN IT CAME OUT.
WHY IS ANYBODY SURPRISED?
THAT’S MY QUESTION.
RUSSIAN ELECTION INTERFERENCE
GOES BACK DECADES.
AS WE HAVE BEEN REPORTING AN FBI
INFORMANT THAT IS NOW TALKING TO
THREE SEPARATE CONGRESSIONAL
COMMITTEES AND JUST THE LAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS DISCOVERED BACK
IN 2009 UNDERCOVER FOR SIX
YEARS, ALL TOLD 30 YEARS IN HIS
LIFE, HE NOTICED IN 2009 THIS
WAS AN INFORMANT, WITH THE FBI,
ABOUT A PLAN THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN
HAD TO CORNER AMERICA’S URANIUM
MARKET.
THIS ALL STARTED IN 2009.
THEN HE DISCOVERED THERE WAS
BRIBERY, KICKBACKS, MONEY
LAUNDERING, RACKETEERING AND
OTHER TYPES OF EXTORTION GOING O
THE FBI RUN BY RONALD MUELLER,
WERE BEING THEED EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY.
AND THEY DID NOTHING.
ROBERT MUELLER HAS QUESTIONS TO
ANSWER.
AND THIS INFORMANT SAYS RUSSIA
PAID MILLIONS TO A LOBBYING FIRM
IN AN ATTEMPT TO INFLUENCE THEN
SECRETARY OF STATE HILLARY
CLINTON.
THAT COMPANY DENY THE
ALLEGATIONS.
NOW, THIS PUTIN-LED OPERATION IN
2009, NOBODY IN THE MEDIA IS
TELLING YOU, STARTED YEARS
BEFORE, A YEAR AND A HALF BEFORE
THE BOARD, NINE OBAMA FEDERAL
AGENCIES INCLUDING HILLARY AS
SECRETARY OF STATE, ERIC HOLDER
AT JUSTICE, APPROVED THE SALE OF
URANIUM ONE.
KEY PLAYERS INVOLVED IN THAT
DECISION, THEY SHOULD HAVE KNOWN
ALL THIS WAS GOING ON.
BUT THEY APPROVED IT ANYWAY.
AND THE REAL QUESTION IS,
KNOWING ALL OF THIS, KNOWING
PUTIN’S EFFORTS IN ’09 AND THAT
WE DIDN’T HAVE ENOUGH URANIUM IN
AMERICA WHY WOULD ALL OF THESE
AGENCIES AND THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, WHY DID THEY
ALLOW RUSSIA A HOSTILE FOREIGN
ENTITY TO TAKE CONTROL OF 20% OF
OUR URANIUM?
THE FOUNDATIONAL MATERIAL TO
MAKE NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
WE’RE SUPPOSED TO BE SURPRISED
TODAY’S INDICTMENTS?
HERE’S THE OTHER ASPECT OF ALL
OF THIS, THE LEFT, CORRUPT MEDIA
WON’T TELL YOU ABOUT.
THE RUSSIAN INFLUENCE CAMPAIGN,
GOES BACK TO 2014.
WHERE THE HELL IS THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION?
WHAT DID THEY DO THEN TO STOP
THIS.
REMEMBER, NBC NEWS REPORTED
AFTER THE ELECTION THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION DIDN’T DO MORE TO
STOP RUSSIA BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT
HILLARY WAS GOING TO WIN.
THAT’S NBC.
SO IN OTHER WORDS IT SOUNDS LIKE
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION, THEY
WERE COMPLICIT IN THIS, THEY
DROPPED THE BALL.
AND THEY WERE DEFINITELY IN THIS
CASE MORE WARNING SIGNS YOU CAN
SHAKE A STICK AT.
IN APRIL 2016, THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
DEVIN NUNES WARNED AMERICA’S
INABILITY TO PREDICT VLADIMIR
PUTIN’S PLANS WOULD BE THE
BIGGEST INTELLIGENCE FAILURE
THAT WE HAVE HAD SINCE 9/11.
HOW SADLY ROIMENT HE WAS.
BARACK OBAMA NEEDS TO TELL YOU,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, WHAT HE
KNEW AND WHEN HE KNEW IT.
MAYBE OBAMA DIDN’T TAKE THE
RUSSIAN THREAT SERIOUSLY.
REMEMBER IN THE 201 ELECTION
DURING.
DEBATE, HE WAS MOCKING MITT
ROMNEY.
MITT ROMNEY WAS WARNING ABOUT
THE RUSSIAN THREAT.
TAKE LOOK.
>> GOVERNOR ROMNEY, I’M GLAD
THAT YOU RECOGNIZE THAT AL QAEDA
IS A THREAT.
A FEW MONTHS AGO WHEN YOU WERE
ASKED THE BIGGEST GEOPOLITICAL
THREAT YOU SAID RUSSIA.
NOT AL QAEDA.
YOU SAID RUSSIA.
IN THE 1980s, NOW CALLING TO SKR
FOR YOUR FOREIGN POLICY BACK.
THE COLD WAR HAS BEEN OVER FOR
20 YEARS.
>> Sean: A YEAR LATER PUTIN HAD
HIS PEOPLE BRIBING, EXTORTING,
MONEY LAUNDERING IN AMERICA TO
GET INVOLVED IN OUR URANIUM
MAFERKTS.
GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW, PRESIDENT
OBAMA AND TOP MEMBERS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION OWE YOU AN
EXPLANATION.
HILLARY OWES YOU AN EXPLANATION.
WHAT THIS DID IS A DERELICTION
OF DUTY.
THEY FAIL TO STOP A MAJOR
NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT.
WE DID REACH OUT TO OBAMA’S
OFFICE FOR COMMENTS, SHOCKINGLY
WE HAVEN’T HEARD BACK.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF RUSSIAN
COLLUSION, IS THE CLIN TO BE
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR -- CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DOSSIER
FILLED WITH RUSSIAN AND RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT LIES AND PROPAGANDA.
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE DNC
SHELLED OUT OVER $12 MILLION TO
FUND THIS SALACIOUS AND
UNVERIFIED DOSSIER USED AS THE
BULK OF INFORMATION TO GET A
FISA WARRANT TO SPY ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THE SAME DOSSIER THE REPUBLICAN
MEMOS FOUND THAT THE FBI USED TO
LIE IN THAT FISA COURT TO GET
THAT WARRANT TO SPY ON A MEMBER
OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THE FBI, FUSION GPS, NOBODY
VERIFIED WHAT WAS IN THE
DOSSIER, TO THIS DAY WE HAVEN’T
PROVEN A THING IN THE DOSSIER.
WE KNOW THAT THE BULK OF THAT
FISA APPLICATION WAS MADE UP OF
A POLITICAL HIT PIECE DOCUMENT
PUT TOGETHER BY A FORMER PLITISH
SPY, CHRISTOPHER STEEL, USING
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT SOURCES AND
SOME OF HILLARY’S BEST FRIEND AS
SOURCES.
NOW, ALSO BREAKING, A LOT OF
DEVELOPMENTS TONIGHT AS IT
RELATES TO THE CASE OF BRUCE AND
NELLIE ORR.
THIS HUGS BAND AND WIFE DUO, WE
REPORTED AFTER BRUCE ORR
HIGH-RANKING JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL PASSED ON THE
ANTI-TRUMP FIELD DOSSIER, HE
GAVE IT TO THE FBI.
IT WAS HIS WIFE, NELLIE, WORKING
FOR FUSION GPS ON THE DOSSIER.
ACCORDING TO A REPORT IN THE
DAILY CALLER, BRUCE OHR
ATTEMPTED TO HIDE HIS WIFE’S
INVOLVEMENT WITH FUSION GPS BY
NOT DISCLOSING ON REQUIRED LEGAL
ETHIC FORMS GEL NELLIE OHR WAS
PAID BY FUSION GPS.
HE LISTED HIS WIFE AS CYBER
SECURITY ANALYST AND DID NOT
DISCLOSE FUSION GPS IN ANY WAY.
ACCORDING TO THE REPORT BRUCE
OHR, QUOTE, DID NOT OBTAIN A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST WAIVER FROM
HIS SUPERIORS AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
WAS BRUCE OHR INTENTIONALLY
COVERING UP HIS WIFE’S
INVOLVEMENT FOR FUSION GPS AND
THE RUSSIAN DOSSIER?
GIVEN THAT INTENTIONALLY
FALSIFYING GOVERNMENT ETHICS
DOCUMENTS RESULTS IN JAIL TIME
IS MUELLER’S INVESTIGATION, ARE
THEY GOING TO CHARGE BRUCE OHR?
DON’T HOLD YOUR BREATH.
NEW INFORMATION ABOUT JAMES
COMEY’S MEMOS.
BYRON YORK WASHINGTON EXAMINER
POINTS OUT VERY INTERESTING
ARTICLE WITH THE HEADLINE, WHY
ARE THE COMEY MEMOS SECRET.
BYRON YORK IS REPORTING THAT IN
JULY OF 2017 THE FBI ALLOWED
LAWMAKERS SEE THE MEMO ABOUT
COMEY’S VERSION OF CONVERSATIONS
THAT HE HAD WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
LATER LEAKED TO THE PROFESSOR
THAT LEAKED TO THE FBI THAT LED
TO ROBERT MUELLER.
THE FBI MADE SURE THE
INFORMATION IN THESE MEMOS WAS
SEVERELY RESTRICTED.
WHY WOULD THAT BE?
COMEY TESTIFIED UNDER OATH THAT
HE GAVE THE MEMOS TO THAT
FRIEND, THEY LEAKED TO THE "NEW
YORK TIMES," IN THE HOPES THAT
ROBERT MUELLER WOULD BE
APPOINTED AS SPECIAL COUNSEL.
IT HAPPENED.
YOU WOULD THINK IF THOSE MEMOS
WERE SO DAMNING AND DAMAGING AND
EXPLOSIVE AND PROVED OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE WHICH WE HEAR ABOUT,
LIKE COMEY AND THE MEDIA AND THE
DEMOCRATS CLAIM, WHY DON’T WE
RELEASE THE MEMOS.
THEY ARE KEEPING THEM SECRET FOR
A REASON.
LOOK AT CONGRESSMAN TREY GOWDY,
SOUTH CAROLINA, SKRIEBLD THE
MEMOS IN DECEMBER.
DESCRIBED THE MEMOS.
>> OBSTRUCTION OF JULES
ADVERTISE WAS DISCUSSED WHEN
COMBO HAD COMEY HAD THE MEMOS.
THEY WOULD BE DEFENSE EXHIBIT A
IN OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE CASE.
NOT PROSECUTION EXHIBIT.
DEFENSE EXHIBIT A.
IF COMEY FELT OBSTRUCTED, HE DID
A MASTERFUL JOB OF KEEPING IT
OUT OF ANY OF HIS MEMOS.
>> Sean: DEFENSE EXHIBIT A.
THE ENTIRE SO-CALLED SCANDAL
WITH THE MEMO KREE AMOUNTED BY
COMEY, PERPETRATED BY THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE LEFT WING
MEDIA, ABSOLUTELY A FARCE, A
MERE POLITICAL TACTIC.
USED TO DAMAGE PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND UNDERMINE HIS PRESIDENCY.
ALL OF THE COMEY MEMOS SHOULD BE
RELEASED.
ALSO TONIGHT WHILE TODAY’S